[Musique]
enfin ce qui est arrivé sanitaires on
n'a pas peur
nous avons eu la liberté c'est par où
commencer ça fait partie de la vie de ce
club
non
j'ai 23 ans pour et le dernier cyclone
que j'ai vu j'étais très petit donc j'ai
pas bien compris que ça va on va dès que
c'est la première une photo ce match les
infos et quand même je croise rafales de
vent c'est vraiment un peu énorme quand
même
[Musique]
m
payant il ya plus tôt quand j'écris une
bouteille d'eau c'est la hausse pour le
dépanne est dit mais je pense que je
vais faire
fihri dans un autre magasin vous prouver
que votre parce que ces instances à moi
j'ai besoin d'eau et puis quand il pleut
l'eau du robinet et invita pour les
bruins
[Musique]